[Musique]
lui qui nous a fait un festival cette
année ça reste quand même jean michel
jean michel maire
si vous suivez l'émission quelques fois
où beaucoup jean michel maire c'est
vraiment je crois comme aujourd'hui que
le disais c'est sa meilleure année je
sais pas si c'est sa meilleure année
parce que le problème c'est que le
garçon n'a plus de filtre oui si sa main
ce qui est bien c'est que tout sort et
puis avec de très bonnes vannes c'est
pour ça que l'année prochaine on aura
quelqu'un du csa voilà treize ans sur le
plateau quelqu'un qui vous fasse des
décharges électriques la mesa pilotage
fur et à mesure et bien jean michel
maire cette année
regardez c'était ça et jean mi et chez
vous aussi regardez bien parce qu'on est
une énorme surprise pour vous dans ce
bagne et où quand une surprise c'est une
vraie surprise et mon jour me
je pense que tu vas être ému mon chéri
regarde je pense que c'est la meilleure
saison de jean-michel me retrousser d'un
des meilleurs et je le trouve voilà
excellents cette année vous avez fait
hier soir j'ai donné pas mal de plaisir
c'était très sympa je l'embrassé
vraiment j'ai pouvoir après manger quoi
ah non on est passé directement de
seurre banana split
l'on fait tourner une quête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ceux qui s'avancent on plonge un petit
beaucoup on pollue aussi
j'ai un dj magnifique lire le dise
robail comme ça tu touches
vous savez donc moi pc gpu c'est à dire
un petit cube grosse poitrine
pis pour mambo et j'avais un crunch pour
une journaliste hongroise crunch
certains moments j'avais la moitié
d'année rime pas avec une don et je les
objets me laver le nez avec la borne et
les manchots c'est normal c'est parce
que depuis tout petit on n'en dit pas de
bras pas de choc
vois tu faisais que ça en douce
maintenant il demande à tanger française
française
ces numéros ma chambre 20h c'est le ton
j'accorderai à chacune d'entre vous 24
bonne cap c'est la taille par de ma loge
et oui concède concept et je vous le dis
si vous tes pour moi
charest serait peut-être de keith
jarrett ray personnes arrêtées figurent
immersion
alors jean michel est déjà soumis ciel
est ténue mais jean michel geay
magnifique surprise pop est un bon
résumé de sa carrière je vous sens déjà
ému aujourd'hui
bah ouais pas loin de chez moi content
d'être à mes côtés depuis sept ans
françois ya eu évidemment chaque année
un peu plus
moi je vous adore chaque année un peu
plus ces gens m'embrouiller tous les
noms jala je suis un bon fond alors
c'est vrai que c'est un vraie
gentillesse et c'est vrai que c'est
dingue parce que je suis un petit peu
enfin je dis pas ça mais c'est vrai que
je suis un petit pont d'un petit peu je
suis choquée tout comme votre confrère
ou la wii ça s'est super je m'occupe de
lui je vois qu'elles auront ce soir
quand il fait des conneries c'est moi
qu'on appelle jamais à ça mais je laime
vraiment énormément aux jambes y est
c'est un garçon vraiment je pense que
tant que tu es pmp existera jean niveau
faible à l'autre selon michel sera avec
nous est jamais vu la faille jamais
demain selon michel c'est vraiment joli
j'ai remis mon chéri on a une très très
belle surprise pour vous regarder
vraiment je pense que ça va vous faire
plaisir il ya des gens qui tenais à vous
remercier ou là pour une fois c'est pas
une connerie regarde beaucoup mangent en
ligne vient d'apprendre que tu as naître
et lumière chroniqueur l'année c'est
vraiment c'est super
ça va redonner l'espoir à tous les
glands de la terre et que même si tu es
parfois d'humour d'or apocalytique parce
que c'est vrai que de temps en temps ça
dépasse l'entendement quand même
et bien tu es aussi un garçon très
adorable généreux toujours présent quoi
qu'il arrive bref tu es un vrai gentil
et ça ça mérite encore plus un prix
bonjour frérot est bien comme tu vois je
vais faire un petit coucou du travail où
nous on travaille sérieusement pas comme
certains ébats te félicite pour ton prix
de meilleur chroniqueur de l'année et
puis on te fait des grand'maisons coucou
jean-michel félicitations pourtant
tracée je ne sais pas sur quelles bases
qui a été élue peut-être pourtant
travail acharné mais j'ai un petit doute
ou alors parce que tu es toujours prêt à
être lourd comme des scieries et à dire
des bêtises allez encore bravo bisous et
à bientôt à glaris aux images
ils ont paris qui était qui est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire qu'ils étaient
toutes ces paires en premier c'était ma
grande soeur
après avec mon la mère de ma fille après
c'était ma petite soeur qui est la fille
revient dans une clinique dans l'est et
après ma maman est ce que
malheureusement l'habitat bio y songe à
voix très peu j'ai avec deux fois par an
donc là je la vois je suis super m vous
la faites marrer votre maman j'ai fait
marrer oui je sais pas si je crois
qu'elle préférait que j'étais au figaro
mettez plus qu'ils aient tout à mon fils
et au tri au figaro il a acheté et
papier et web a très envie à quaresma la
top de votre fils
[Rires]
mais malgré tout je m'amuse plus
longtemps qu'avant lui dans les normes
et jean-michel en tout cas nous on vous
aime fort et on vous lâchera jamais moi
je vous dis donnez moi je pense qu'on va
encore donner
[Applaudissements]